The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR NELSON: Well, today
we're going to continue with
the lecture that was started
last time that had the
scintillating and descriptive
title "some thermodynamic
processes".
And we're going to continue
along those lines, and really
there a couple of things that I
want to do to follow up what
you saw last time.
One is that you've got
introduced and led through a
couple of elementary
thermodynamic cycles.
And I want to do a little
bit more of that today.
And one of the -- there are
really two reasons.
One is that as you saw last
time doing a thermodynamic
cycle can be extremely useful,
because if you have one path
along which some change occurs,
but along which it's
not necessarily easy to
calculate all of the
thermodynamic changes along
such a path, it may be
irreversible, lots of variables
may change.
It can be easier instead of
looking at the complicated
path to devise a cycle that
involves several easier steps,
each one of which is facile for
the calculation of what
happens to the thermodynamic
properties.
So in that case, it's much
easier to go through several
elementary step, and then the
one complicated path you know
because going around the entire
cycle state functions,
you know that they won't
have any change.
So in that sense, going through
a thermodynamic cycle
can be useful because it
helps you calculate
thermodynamic qualities.
But the other reason to go
through the thermodynamic
cycles and really to develop
great facility with them is
because there are just an awful
lot of things in nature
and things that we build that
run in cycles, where we want
to calculate the thermodynamics,
right.
If we build an engine for a
car or anything else, it
almost always is going to have
some key element that's
operating in a cycle,
otherwise it
won't keep going, right.
But it's not just engines
that we might build.
It's biological engines,
right.
Things that either produce or
consume biological fuel to do
different sorts of processes.
Also, of course of key
importance to understand what
the, in that case, biological
thermodynamics are.
And again, there'll be key
elements that run in cycles
and understanding those can
be extremely important in
understanding how cellular
function works.
OK, so what I'd like to do is go
through one cycle, and then
I'll suggest another for you to
work through on your own.
So consistent with the title
of the lecture, we've got a
section from your last lecture
notes entitled "some
thermodynamic cycles".
And what we're going to do is
go through a cycle, please
note these office hours and
locations, which I think
wasn't specified before.
So we're going to go through
a thermodynamic cycle, and
here's what I want to calculate
when we do this.
Delta u, delta H, familiar state
functions, changes in
their values, q, w,
heat and work.
And I also want to introduce
one new function.
I won't give it a name yet,
but it's going to have the
unusual form dq over
T. OK, we'll
call it special function.
It's so special that we'll
call this quantity dS.
OK, we'll just go through this
on a whim, and this is going
to be foreshadowing something
that'll take on tremendous
importance in subsequent
lectures, but I'm going to use
the opportunity now to just
introduce the behavior of it
in going around a cycle.
If that's for me, tell
them I'm busy please.
OK, so let's look at the
cycle we'll go through.
We're going to look at pressure
volume changes,
similar to what you
saw before.
This time, we're going to have
initial and final volumes, V1
and V2 and different pressures
where we might end up.
And we're going to look
at two ways to go to a
final volume V2.
One of them is going to end up
at pressure p2 and the other
is going to end up
at pressure p3.
One of them is going to be a
reversible isothermal path.
This is going to be our path
we'll label A, reversible
isothermal which is to say
constant T, right?
And we're going to start at
temperature T1, so since it's
constant temperature, this
is going to end up
at temperature T1.
And then we're also going
to consider a reversible
adiabatic path.
This'll be our path B,
reversible adiabatic.
And then we'll close this
circle, this cycle.
This is going to end
up at a different
temperature by the way.
You saw this last time in a
slightly different way.
Last time what you saw is we
compared isothermal and
adiabatic paths that ended up
at the same final pressure,
and what you saw is that
therefore, they ended up in
different final volumes.
So this is just a little bit
different from that.
So this is going to end up at a
different temperature, we'll
call it T2.
And then we're going
to close the cycle.
And so this is a constant
volume path then.
This is path C, constant
volume.
OK?
So now let's go around the cycle
and just compare notes
on what happens to
the thermodynamic
quantities as we do that.
So here's path A,
it's isothermal.
And I didn't specify, but let's
make sure to do so,
we've got a, it's going
to be an ideal gas.
OK, so A is constant
temperature.
What does that mean for
delta u in path A?
Zero right?
Ideal gas, no temperature
change, right has to be zero
because da is Cv dT for an ideal
gas. dT is zero, there's
no temperature change.
OK, how about delta H, zero
Cp dT for an ideal gas.
dT is zero.
All right, now, it's
reversible.
So that means we can immediately
write down an
expression for the work.
Since it's reversible, it's
negative p dV right?
And since it's an ideal gas then
we can replace p, right,
with RT over V, right?
We want to do that because we
have too many variables here.
We've already got dV we'll get
rid of p as an additional
variable and replace it with
V which is already in here.
So it's minus R T1
dV over V, right?
I can put in T1 because we're a
constant temperature. so now
we can just integrate straight
away and find that the work in
path A it's just the integral
of that quantity minus
integral of R T1 going from V1
to V2 dV over V. so it's minus
R T1 log V2 over V1.
All right, so let's just do
a reality check here.
The way I've got this
drawn, the volume is
going up in the process.
It's an expansion.
So is this system doing work
on the surroundings, or are
the surroundings doing
work on the system?
Somebody say it real loud.
Yes, the system is working on
the surroundings, right?
It's pushing out against them.
Work is defined as the work that
the surroundings do on
the system.
So this is the negative
number, right?
V2 is bigger than V1.
This is positive.
This whole thing is negative.
All right, q has to be just the
opposite of this because
we've already figured out that
there's no change in u.
This is just q plus w.
There's w, q has to be R
T1 log of V2 over V1.
OK, so that means heat is being
imparted to the system,
right, from the surroundings in
a manner that compensates
exactly the amount
of work done.
OK, All right, so these are the
thermodynamic quantities
that you're familiar
with already.
Let's just quickly look at
our special function.
It's not going to be hard to
calculate because it's a
constant temperature path,
so that T in the
bottom is just T1, right.
You've already looked
at q, right.
So dq A over T1 it's just
R log V2 over V1 right.
So there's our special
function for
this particular path.
OK, so that's path A. Now let's
compare to path B. So if
path B is an adibat, what's
zero? q, it's adiabatic, that
means there's no heat exchanged
between the system
and the surroundings.
So what happens, q B is zero.
There is a change in
temperature, right?
We've got, if we say it's a mole
of gas, it's going from
p1, V1, and T1 to one mole of
our gas at p3, V2, and T2.
So unlike before now
temperature is going to change.
So that means that delta
u isn't zero this time.
du, it's an ideal gas.
So this is Cv dT and of course
we can just integrate this
straight away.
So delta u B is Cv times T2
minus T1, right. and similarly
dH is Cp dT right.
So delta H in pathway B is
just Cp T2 minus T1 okay?
All right, what we've already
got that q is zero.
Delta u is q plus w.
Delta u isn't zero.
So this must be equal
to work, right?
And now we can look at our
special function, but since
this is zero right dq B is zero,
along path B, so our
special function, dS, so we're
going to go, dq B over T is
equal to zero.
OK?
OK, finally let's look at our
third path, this constant
volume path, that's going to
connect T1 and T2, right?
Constant volume, what's zero?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR NELSON: A little
more noise here.
What's zero?
STUDENT: Work.
PROFESSOR NELSON: Work, great.
So, path C constant volume means
our work in past C is
zero, right?
Now, our temperature is going
to change from T2 to T1, and
we just saw what happens to u
and H when that happens going
from T1 to T2, and it's
no different.
It's an ideal gas going
along these path.
So we can immediately write
delta u C is Cv
times T1 minus T2.
Delta Hc C is Cp times
T1 minus T2, right?
Work is zero.
Delta u is w plus q,
work plus heat.
This is zero, this isn't.
This must be heat q B, right.
So again, there are our
familiar thermodynamic
quantities, but now let's also
look at our special function.
It's not going to be zero this
time because we have non zero
heat exchange between
the system and the
environment, right.
So are integral of dq C over T,
right, which is our heat,
but in this case we can do
this calculation easily
because since work is zero, we
can equate dq with du, right.
So we can write this as our
integral from T1 to T2, du
over T. du is just
Cv dT, right.
So this is just Cv
log T2 over T1.
OK?
So now we've completed
the cycle.
So let's just compare.
Let's compare what happened in
path A to what happened in
paths B and C. Yes?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR NELSON: Ah sorry,
yes of course.
Thank you.
Yes, oh yes, so.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR NELSON: And it's
right because, thank you
again, it's because we're
going from T1 to T2.
So I'm getting confused
by the oh sorry, we're
going from T2 to T1.
So it's in reverse of the order
of the subscripts and I
let this confuse me.
There it is.
There.
Thank you, any other details
which should be pointed out?
All right, then let's proceed.
So what we're going to do is
our comparison of what
happened on pathway A to what
happened in combined pathways
B and C, right?
So here are results for pathway
A, right, for delta u
zero delta H zero.
I didn't actually explicitly
write it or did I?
Let's just write it again.
Here's our work in path A, and
here's our heat exchange in
path A. Now let's look at the
sum of B and C. So B plus C,
here is delta uB Cv
times T2 minus T1.
Delta uC Cv times T1 minus T2,
the sum is zero right.
That's the some of delta u in
these two paths, and if we
look at delta u in just
path A, it's zero.
And it's going to be the same
without delta H. The only
difference is it'll be Cp
instead of Cv, but there it is
for pathway B. There it is for
a pathway C. So the state
functions that we're familiar
with are doing what we expect
they ought to be doing, right?
If you go around in a cycle,
starting and ending at the
same place, the state functions
have to stay the same.
They only depend on the state
the system is in.
They don't depend on the
path, and that's what
we've shown, right.
Similarly if we go from this
point to this point through
path A or if we do it through
the combination of these two
paths, and the change in u and H
in any state function, those
have to be the same.
It turns out they're zero in
both cases, and that's what
we've seen, right?
Now let's compare what happens
to work and heat.
So here are expressions
for work and heat.
They're opposites for the
pathway A. Here's pathway B
and C. In C the work is zero.
In B it isn't, it's Cv times
T2 minus T1, right.
The work isn't equal to the
work in pathway A, right,
because you know work is not a
state function it depends on
the path right, and there are
different amounts of work done
on the system, or done by the
system on the surroundings in
these two different processes.
They're both expansions.
They'll both have net work done
on the surroundings, but
not the same amount, right.
And of course it's going to
be the same with heat.
We've already seen that
delta u is zero.
So we know that in each case
the heat is going to be the
opposite of the work, but the
work isn't the same in these
two different ways of getting
from here to here, right.
So let's just see
it explicitly.
Here's our qA.
Here's heat exchanged in pathway
A and in pathway B
heat is zero, and in pathway
C, here is qC
it's Cv T1 minus T2.
So again, for both heat
and work we don't
get the same result.
Now let's look at our special
function, right.
So here's path A. We found that
it's R log V2 over V1.
Pathway B is zero.
Pathway C it's Cv
log T1 over T2.
All right, let's just look at
that a little more carefully.
R log V2 over V1.
B plus C, Cv log of
T1 over T2, right.
Just some weird combination
of functions, right?
But, of course, it's not
quite like that.
Why?
Because this path is
an adiabatic path.
And you already saw last time
there was this relationship
between the temperature and
volume changes along an
adiabatic path.
So let me just write
that down.
Adiabatic reversible path.
What you saw is that T1 over
T2 was V2 over V1 to the
power R over Cv.
Isn't that something?
So what does that mean?
We take this Cv and put in
the exponent here, right.
And we put this R up in
the exponent here.
What are we going to discover?
Those two things are equal
right, T1 over T2 to the power
Cv is V2 over V1 to the power R,
so dS over path A equals dS
over paths B plus C, okay?
So what this suggests is that
whatever this funny special
function is, at least for this
one cycle that we've, tried
it's behaving like a state
function, right.
It seems like its change
is independent of path.
Start here, end up here, do
it through two different
pathways, end up in the
same place, right.
OK, now that's all the
foreshadowing I'm going to
give it for right now.
We will certainly come
back to this very
special function shortly.
Before I move on, I'm just
going to put on the board
another cycle, and I'm going
to urge you to work through
that on your own.
It's worked through already,
let's see, I believe it's
worked through in
the notes, yes.
So if you need the help of the
notes it's in there, but I
would urge you to work through
it on your own, and it's the
following: let's start with the
same path A, all right?
So we've got our reversible
adiabatic path right.
And now, try working through
what happens if we close the
cycle in a different way,
right, like this.
So here's a path that's constant
pressure, and here is
a path that's constant volume,
similar to the constant volume
path that we did before, but
not between the same
pressures, right.
So we can label this one D and
this one E, and I urge you to
just try going through that
and verifying for yourself
that again the state functions
will behave the way state
functions should, and you can
see whether this special
function once again behaves like
a state function, right.
And of course you should expect
to see that the work
and the heat again won't behave
like state functions
which they are, then you'll see
you have different results
for those, depending
on the path, OK?
Any questions about going
through these cycles and using
expressions like this
and so forth?
Expressions like this you know
turn up in various places,
like in the equations sheet
that appears at the end of
exams, right?
Which means that you
may not need to be
committing it to memory.
On the other hand it means that
you should, it's the sort
of thing that you should be
familiar with so that the need
to use it is something that
you'll conjure when you're
working on a problem and there's
a reversible adiabat,
and you have temperatures and
volumes that change that you
might like to relate
to each other.
Cycles that are suggested that
you go through and aren't gone
through in class also sometimes
turn up on exams
too, by the way.
So that said, let's move on to
the next topic, which is
thermochemistry.
So, so far what you've seen in
most of the examples in the
class are essentially mechanical
kinds of changes,
pressure volume sorts of
changes, where the system is
doing essentially a kind of
mechanical work, pressure
volume work on the surroundings
or vice versa and
heat is being exchanged, and
you're calculating the basic
thermodynamics just like
we went through, of
processes of that sort.
Now I'd like to start
introducing something that's
really central to chemical
thermodynamics, mainly
chemistry, right.
Let's start looking at chemical
reactions, right, and
understanding what the changes
in thermodynamic properties
are that occur when chemical
reactions occur, and the
immediate application is to
calculate the change in
enthalpy, which, as you've seen
it, at constant pressure
which is the condition under
which an awful lot of
chemistry is done, that's
just the heat.
Which means we're going
to calculate heats
of reaction, right.
You're running some reaction.
It's in the atmosphere.
It's at constant pressure.
You know, you mix acid and base
together and the thing
heats up like crazy, right.
Or other things might
react spontaneously.
You can feel something
cooling off right.
I mean simple examples of these
happen when you, you
know, if you buy cold
or hot packs.
You break the seal between them
and feel the thing get
cold, for example, right.
What's happening there?
Well, the selection of reactants
has been done
judiciously to provide either
heat or to provide something
that's cool.
And all of that is coming out
of the heat of reaction,
whether it's positive
or negative.
Of course the biggest practical
application is
burning of fuel.
You might use the heat to, and
convert it into pressure
volume work, right?
So if it's an internal
combustion
engine, you'll do a reaction.
There will be the heat
of reaction.
There'll be a volume change,
depending on the conditions
under which is occurs, and you
can extract work through the
reaction and so forth.
So let's just to see how you
run through some of those
calculations.
Now let me just ask who
here took 5.111?
And who here took 5.112?
OK, now you've seen some
thermal chemistry
in 5.111 and 5.112.
So I I'm going to do some review
of that, but I'm also
going to call on the
thermochemistry that I'm
pretty sure you're
familiar with.
So I won't go painstakingly
over every element of the
notes here.
Subsequently we'll go on into
additional topics that you
haven't seen, and I'll treat
them in full detail.
OK, so let's do some
thermochemistry.
What we want to do is we'd like
to be able to predict for
any reaction what's the
heat of reaction.
And so what we're going to
calculator is delta H. So for
any kind of reaction we should
be able to do that, right?
And we're going to treat
constant pressure situations
certainly at first and most
of the time, right?
Constant pressure, right,
reversible delta H is going to
give us our heat of
reaction, OK.
And then if we can also
determine delta u, then we
know this, we know delta u
is q plus w, then we can
determine work as well, right?
And typically, we'll be treating
at least some cases
where we're dealing with ideal
gases in which case we can
easily get delta u.
And then we'll be able
to in a very
straightforward way get w.
So it's a really powerful and
simple formalism, once we set
up what is needed the go
through it, right?
So let's just consider
any reaction.
The one that I've got written
down for you is it's the
reverse of the rusting
of iron, right?
So iron left to own devices in
the atmosphere in the presence
of a little bit of water, and
the atmosphere will start
combining with the water
form iron oxide.
There's an equilibrium
between the two.
So we'll have an iron
oxide species.
It's a solid.
It's combining with hydrogen
which is a gas to give iron,
also a solid and water, right?
So the way I've written this
we're imagining the iron, the
solid iron immersed in the water
as a liquid, could be
calculated otherwise as well,
but in this case were imaging
the water as liquid and going
in this direction then it's
forming iron oxide and evolving
hydrogen gas, okay?
And our heat of reaction or
enthalpy of reaction is
defined as the enthalpy
at constant pressure.
Isothermal conditions,
temperature won't change and
reversible work.
For Isothermal reaction
constant
pressure reversible, right?
Of course, they're all sorts
of conditions under which a
reaction could be wrong
in the lab or
outdoors or however, right.
But this is the way
we're going to
define delta H of reaction.
We want to have that definition
clear because in
fact we're going to, we might
want tabulate heats of
reaction, right, and of course
want to know what the
conditions are for the tabulated
values apply.
And we're going to want to
calculate them from other
quantities, and again, we're
going to need to know each
case what are the relevant
conditions?
OK, so what happens?
Well, we should be
able to get this.
We should be able to
calculate delta H.
It's a state function.
If we know the enthalpy of the
products minus the enthalpy of
the reactants, right.
It's a state function.
And we can we can do this in
principle except for one
important detail, which is
that enthalpy, just like
energy u isn't measured on an
absolute scale but on a
relative scale, right?
You know, if you want to measure
the potential energy
of something in a gravitational
field, you have
to define the zero somewhere,
right, because it's arbitrary.
You can set it anywhere
you want.
It's the same with enthalpy.
Enthalpy is just u plus p V. So
there is an arbitrary set
point that needs to
be defined, right?
Because what you actually
measure in the lab are changes
in enthalpy, just like what you
measure when you look at
energy change of some sort,
you measure the change in
energy, right.
The absolute number that you
assign to it is something
that's arbitrary.
You have to set what
the zero is.
And so there's a well-understood
convention for
what the zero is.
What we define as zero is the
enthalpy of every element in
its natural state at room
temperature and ambient pressure.
In other words, we choose a
convention for the zero of
entropy, so that then we can
write entropies of products
and reactants always referring
to the same standard state.
And then we calculate changes,
the convention is understood
with respect to what
is the zero, right.
And so our tabulated values,
they'll all work.
They'll all refer to the
same standard state.
And we'll be able to use the
formalism that we set up.
So our reference point for H,
it's 298.15 Kelvin, one bar
and in that standard state our
molar enthalpy is defined as
zero for every element
in its stable form.
OK, very important.
OK, now, given that reference
point, all we need to do to
get the value of enthalpy that
we're going to use for each
reactant and each product is
calculate how much does the
enthalpy change to form it from
the elements in their
stable form at room temperature
and pressure, right.
So we're going to replace the H
or we're going to put in for
the H what we'll call our heat
of formation or delta H of
formation starting from the
elements in their stable
states at room temperature
and pressure, for
each of these things.
And we can do that because now
we're going to have instead of
just sort of H, it's going to
be delta H of formation for
each of these things, is going
to appear in our calculation
of H, but that's OK.
Delta H of formation means the
enthalpy of this compound
minus the enthalpy of its
constituent elements in their
most stable state at room
temperature and pressure.
But we've defined the enthalpy
of those elements in their
stable state at room temperature
and pressure as
zero, right?
So we're just subtracting, in
effect, zero, right, from the
enthalpy of the product, but of
course it's important have
that established because the
heat of formation is something
you could measure, right?
You could run the reaction,
take solid iron, gaseous
oxygen, form iron oxide, measure
the heat of formation
of it, tabulate it.
We know it.
We know it forever, right.
And for any of the
other compounds.
So in other words, by defining
that reference state, we can
then figure out or measure heats
of formation of a vast
number of compounds.
We can tabulate them.
We can know them, and then when
we have reactions that
inter-convert different
compounds, we can calculate
the heat of reaction is just
the difference between the
heat of formation of the
reactants, and the heat of
formation of the products,
right.
So let's just write that out.
So first of all, for example,
right, molar enthalpy of
hydrogen gas at 298.15
K is zero.
Hydrogen gas it's in its most
stable state, right at room
temperature and pressure.
That little zero, that
little superscript
means one bar always.
OK.
A molar enthalpy of or whatever,
iron, as a solid at
298.15 Kelvin is zero.
Iron as an element is a solid.
That's it's most stable state
at room temperature and
pressure, right, and so on.
And then we can figure out
heats of formation.
Now in this particular reaction,
I've got hydrogen
gas, iron solid.
Those already are elements in
their most stable forms at
room temperature and pressure.
But this is a compound, right,
it has some non-zero heat of
formation from the elements.
So is water, right?
So I need to find out the heats
of formation of the iron
oxide and the water.
And if I do that then I can
find out the change in
enthalpy of this reaction.
It's just going to be the heat
of formation of these three
moles of water, minus
the heat of
formation of the iron oxide.
OK.
So how am I going to do that?
Well, I need to write the
reaction that forms that
compound from it's
elements, right?
And I want to tabulate that
for an enormous number of
materials, right?
So for example, if I want to
look at HBr, there's a simple
case, right, hydrogen bromine.
What's my heat of formation?
Delta Hf.
It's going to have our
little zero, right?
How do I calculate it?
Well, I need to write the
reaction that forms this from
its constituent elements.
What is it?
Well, 1/2 H2 as a gas,
temperature, at one bar, plus
1/2 bromine, no actually bromine
is a liquid at room
temperature and one
atmosphere.
They form HBr which is a gas
at room temperature and one
bar, right.
I can measure that.
And the heat of reaction for
this, delta H of reaction is
equal to delta H of formation,
of HBr as a gas at our
temperature and one bar, okay?
So that's how we determine
our heats of formation.
We measure them for all
these compounds.
And then we go back to reactions
like this, and we
can just very simply determine
the heat of reaction because
all we're doing is the
following cycle.
We go from reactants to products
and there's some heat
of reaction, and here's the
cycle that we have.
We go to the elements
in their standard
states, in both cases.
So we're really just doing our
delta H is the negative sum of
delta H of formation for the
reactants, all right?
Because here what we're doing
is we're going to take apart
our reactants and form the
elements from them, right?
So written this way, for
example, I'm going to pull
these things apart, and I'm
going to have solid iron, and
I'm going to have gaseous
oxygen, and I know the
enthalpy of that reaction.
That's just given by the heat of
formation, the enthalpy of
formation of iron oxide.
Here, now I'm going to take
those same elements, and I'm
going to make the
products, right.
I know it's going to work
because I already had this
reaction, so all the, you know,
I'm going to conserve
atoms in the right way.
So here, I'm going to have delta
H, is just the sum for
all the products of delta heat
of formation, right?
Here I'm going to put together
all the products.
So this is a positive
heat of formation.
This is the negative heat
of formation, right?
In other words, I've
got reactants,
and I've got products.
What's delta H of reaction?
It's delta H of formation of the
products minus delta H of
formation of the reactants.
That's the important message,
delta H of formation of the
products, minus delta H of
formation of the reactants.
Any questions?
All right, tomorrow I'll go
through the remaining details.
The truth is after this, it's
all arithmetic, right?
We're just going to
go through it and
execute it a little bit.
And then we'll move on and talk
about how we'd actually
make some of these measurements
of delta H and
compare them to what
we calculate.
See you tomorrow.